the videos captured during the robberies
and uploaded to social media
are the work of ariel summers and dean
taylor
the couple followed by millions of
people on social media
hi my name is ariel
and for as long as i can remember
i knew i was going to be famous
[Music]
i never really seen you around here
before
we stroll
[Music]
such a small town i need to get out of
florida
maybe somebody will want to come with me
[Music]
we're gonna need some cash
hope you like green you're in luck
i'm in touch with you yeah i'm gonna
touch it
oh
[Music]
i created a new account 3 000 followers
why would you post that
something like this could make us famous
let's go have some fun
[Music]
you guys have been busy make more money
than you know
you're her aren't you the couple
followed by
millions have been called a modern day
bonnie and clyde
[Music]
how do you think this ends i ain't made
to be no housewife
you don't know what this could do for us
i don't even know what this is anymore
[Music]
nothing like a good old-fashioned bank
robbery
you